IN THE ANGELES CREST
NATIONAL FOREST,
A PLACE WHERE I CAN FIND
AN ANIMAL AND SLAY IT
AND SKIN IT
AND THEN DEVOUR IT.
AND I'M HERE UNDER COVER
OF DARKNESS
BECAUSE THERE SIMPLY
WASN'T TIME
TO ARRANGE
FOR THE NECESSARY PERMITS,
AND SO WE'RE--
WE'RE JUST DOING IT THIS WAY.
I'M ACCOMPANIED
BY MY FATHER-IN-LAW,
JACK WALTHALL,
WHO BROUGHT ALONG THE RIFLE
AND THE HUNTING SMARTS AND ALSO
THE RUGGED INDIVIDUALISM
OF A BYGONE ERA, RIGHT?
- HELLO.
- VERY GOOD.
NOW, JACK, YOU HAD A VERY
INTERESTING AND SORT OF
CLEVER-SOUNDING HUNTING PLOY.
YOU CARE TO SHARE THAT WITH US?
- OH.
WELL, IT'S NOT REALLY
MY IDEA, FORREST.
IT'S S.O.P.--IT'S STANDARD
OPERATING...SOMETHING ELSE.
- UH, RIGHT.
- IT'S DOE'S SCENT.
IT'S ESTRUS URINE OF A DOE.
NOW, THIS WILL ATTRACT A BUCK,
AND THEN ALL YOU NEED TO DO
IS FIRE A BULLET OFF
AT HIS VITAL ORGANS,
AND YOU'RE IN BUSINESS.
- YES, GOOD. OKAY.
VERY GOOD.
THAT'S PRETTY INGENIOUS.
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE,
BUT I'M ABOUT TO TAKE IT
A BIG STEP FORWARD.
JOSH, WILL YOU PLEASE BRING
THE DOE-COY OUT HERE, WON'T YOU?
- OKAY.
- I HAPPENED TO BE IN POSSESSION
OF A NONRETURNABLE
$4,000 SEX DOLL,
AND I WAS EAGER TO FIND
ALTERNATE USES FOR HER.
HER SPECIFIC TALENT SEEMED
PERFECT FOR TONIGHT'S MISSION.
- WHAT IS THAT?
IT LOOKS LIKE
A BEAUTIFUL DEAD LADY.
- YES, WELL, ON ANY OTHER NIGHT,
PERHAPS, BUT TONIGHT SHE IS
THE SEXIEST DOE IN ALL
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
OH, THAT LOOKS GREAT!
THAT'S EVEN BETTER THAN
I THOUGHT IT WOULD LOOK.
- I'VE SEEN WORSE IN BARS,
I'LL TELL YOU.
- [laughs]
- YOU HAVE?
- THAT'S FANTASTIC.
HEY, COME AND GET HER,
ALL YOU BUCKS!
TRUST ME, SHE'S NO PRUDE!
[laughter]
- SHE'S INTO WHATEVER
YOU'RE INTO!
[laughter]
- THAT'S GREAT.
HEY, JOSH, YOU BROUGHT
THE BOLT CUTTERS, RIGHT?
- YEAH, YEAH.
- OKAY, GOOD.
IN TRUTH, THE IDEA OF A FIREARM
IN THE HANDS
OF A 75-YEAR-OLD MAN
IN LOW-VISIBILITY CONDITIONS
MADE ME TERRIBLY NERVOUS,
BUT I WAS DETERMINED
TO CARRY ON FOR THE SAKE
OF HUMAN UNDERSTANDING.
WELL, IT DOES SEEM
A LITTLE BIT CRUEL
TO GET THE BUCKS' HOPES UP
LIKE THIS, YOU KNOW?
THEY THINK THEY'RE GONNA GET
SOME ACTION, RIGHT?
[chuckles]
BUT WHEN YOU'RE HUNTING,
YOU USE EVERY TOOL
AT YOUR DISPOSAL, RIGHT?
WHETHER IT'S A GUN
OR A SUPERIOR INTELLECT.
NOW, MY QUESTION IS,
WHERE THE BEST PLACE--
[tiger roars]
OH!
[all screaming, tiger roaring]
- WHAT THE HECK?
- MR. MACNEIL!
[screaming, animals roaring]
- WHAT'S HAPPENED?
MR. MACNEIL!
- HE'S EATING ME!
[screams]
[animals screeching]
- MR. MACNEIL, WHERE ARE YOU?
- FORREST, WHERE ARE YOU?
- THE TIGER IS ATTACKING ME!
THIS IS A GOD DAMN TIGER!
- I GOT HIM! I GOT HIM!
- HE'S OVER THERE!
- OH, GOD!
- OH, MY [bleep] GOD!
[tiger growls]
- THERE'S A [bleep] TIGER!
- ARE YOU ALL RIGHT?
- NO!
- WHAT CAN WE DO TO HELP?
- SHOOT THE TIGER!
- OH.
STAND BACK.
- [screams]